india is in the grip
of a second wave a deadlier and fast
spreading one this time around
young and old the virus has spared no
one
taking a breath is a struggle
and doctors constantly monitoring every
patient
many just lifeless because of the
disease
the bandra kurla complex kovitt center
with over 2
200 beds is one of the largest
facilities
for kovid 19 patients sky news
was given exclusive access it was set up
last year
as mumbai india's commercial capital
was ravaged by the virus
a year later a repeat the city and state
is reeling once again with record
numbers
the facility is almost full in the
country
i can vaguely tell you that in last few
days or few weeks
there is a upsurge of number of covered
patient
which is labeled as a second wave
undoubtedly considering the number
we can say the second wave has
more virulence than the first wave
but certainly death rate is not not that
much
every day this week india recorded over
200 000 new cases
the highest anywhere in the world
across other states the situation
remains grim
in mdhabad patients attached to oxygen
cylinders
wait their turn in ambulances parked
outside
hospital beds ventilators and even
medicines
have run short
family members wait for a refill of
oxygen cylinders
that is in short supply even in the
national capital delhi
the alarming number of cases has put
tremendous stress
on the health services many cities and
states
have put in restrictions here in delhi
there is a lockdown for the whole week
only essential services are allowed to
be on the road
the fear of a national and prolonged
lockdown
has caused thousands of migrant workers
to rush to railway and bus stations
to return home
[Music]
as the country struggles to deal with
the pandemic
in larger cities the fair is for the
poor and vulnerable
in rural india where health facilities
are inadequate or almost non-existent
never lazarus sky news delhi